do you remember growing up and seeing
stories on the news about young people
in such numbers committing depraved acts
of violence toward others
now there's always been crime and
sometimes horrific crime but I don't
ever recall seeing scenes like the scene
we saw last weekend in Chicago when
people who were just walking in Chicago
minding their own business were set upon
by the mob
hundreds of teens took over downtown
jumping on cars running in traffic you
saw they were smashing Windows two were
shot and motorists were terrorized their
Windows done
and the guys put in their face like
um they were hitting him in the face
so my car is right now
how's your husband is he okay I don't
know
police were outnumbered and overwhelmed
by the Swarm
[Applause]
even the local news decided it was
unsafe and pulled their crew from the
scene
of course this is just the latest though
in a string of disturbing incidents
caught on camera a gas station and
convenience store in Compton California
which of course represents someone's
hard work and paychecks to staff it was
ransacked in a targeted hit
come on
unchecked unpunished chaos just feeds
more criminality
[Music]
and at certain points it almost seems
like a competition for the camera how
cruel how over the top how heartless can
you be
[Applause]
and the humiliation of the Asian
community that seems to be the goal of
some people
cell phone video shows the harrowing
moments when what's described as a bunch
of about 20 teenagers walked into the
fish Village restaurant in College Point
Queens and destroyed the place causing
twenty thousand dollars in Damages
and of course we can't dismiss what
we've seen on school buses we used to
think those were safe where children and
bus drivers alike have been beaten
mercilessly
in Metro Georgia police are reporting
that gang membership is growing
especially among the very young
again gangs have been around for most of
our country's history we all know that
but we're seeing something different
it's much more vicious and it seems more
calculated now these days these these
gangs are Reckless
real Reckless it's not organized no more
it used to be structuring there no women
no kids now it's just a free fall
a free-for-all and permissive attitudes
toward crime and liberal enclaves that's
given gangs the incentive to use younger
kids to commit some of the worst acts of
violence that's new
the ganks are also getting more
sophisticated in their recruiting even
using social media disguising themselves
as public interest organizations
so in a nation-facing recession criminal
gangs are now a growth industry
young people in cities like Chicago know
they have nothing to lose
the Floyd protests took away all
inhibitions
young people were encouraged in fact to
be loud to be disrespectful
they were told that the country is
racist that police are bigots
no wonder so many are angry
and of course the politicians who helped
fuel all of their Fury well they're just
downplaying the consequences
came downtown because it was a great
weather and an opportunity to enjoy the
city that's absolutely entirely
important there are a few that came with
different intentions and they they have
and they will be dealt with
um but I'm not gonna use your language
which I think is I'm wrong to say this
man
an opportunity to enjoy the city
now the response of the incoming mayor
Brandon Johnson who's even worse on
crime than Lightfoot If you can believe
that it was just as weak saying of
course we don't condone the destruction
but we shouldn't demonize those deprived
young people either
well liberal policies help drive both
cultural and economic decline that's
causing this out of control Behavior we
know that so their only response now in
seeing all the damage that's being done
on almost a weekly basis sometimes more
often it's to blame shift
one state Senator Robert Peters claimed
it was all just a mass protest in
Chicago a protest against poverty and
against segregation what
of course that excuse makes no sense
because there was real and widespread
poverty and real government sanctioned
segregation in the south in the 1950s
so why don't we have the same type of
criminality
this degradation and this slide now into
cruel criminal activity
it's not limited to any one race it's
being burned into our national DNA
look at the dead eyes of some of the
worst mass shooters
there was Adam Lanza who killed those
beautiful children at Sandy Hook
Elementary
Dylan roof who killed nine in that black
church in Charleston
then the Pulse Nightclub shooter
then Salvador Ramos the Unspeakable
inflictor of mass damage and Carnage in
Uvalde
and then the Twisted trans killer Audrey
Hale who just killed six at that
Nashville Christian School they're
hiding her Manifesto in other writings
hmm
it's all stomach churning all of it
so many lives lost utter callousness
most Killers seem to suffer from some
deep sense of isolation odd right you're
connected more connected than ever
before with the internet but you're more
lonely and more isolated than ever
before
many of the kids heavily medicated for
depression or anxiety some with
drug-induced psychosis maybe they
started with marijuana
it's many have a deep desire at the same
time for notoriety hence the live
streaming or the last messages posted on
social media before they go carry out
their Carnage it's a lack of empathy and
often a lack of fathers
kids with no guard rails whatsoever can
quickly slip from smoking a little weed
now and then to ending up in a mob
that's stopping a poor passerby as we
saw in Chicago last Saturday night
you have to do better as parents our
kids should not be out here we're out in
pariset that's my question why aren't
they asking where the kids are at right
now are they tracking them they see his
behaviors
are they tracking them no they're not
tracking them
so when so many elected officials and
other powerful people on the left have
spent decades running down this country
and attacking the nuclear family is it
really surprising that many kids have
lost all hope
if Joe Biden thinks America is an evil
place
racist Place systemically racist why
would kids be optimistic today
so politicians have to stop lying to the
American people about the state of
things in this country
the kids aren't all right
children need love and rules laid down
by responsible adults they need
communities that support Parenthood not
make it harder with soft on crime
policies drug legalization and radical
racial and gender propaganda all of that
just undermines churches moms and dads
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else